hello everyone we're going to go ahead
and get started here
in this next talk we have Fabiana
Clemente who will be giving us a
30-minute presentation on the importance
of synthetic data and data Centric Ai
and so just like the last session we'll
have 30 minutes for the speaker and then
five minutes or so for questions
um awesome
so what does it mean the importance of
synthetic dating data Centric AI data
quality in a nutshell so why did a
quality is so important that's that's
where you're going to talk about and why
synthetic data can play a role in it so
I'm Fabiana Clement I'm Chief data
officer at why data my background is in
applied maths I work for big Enterprises
and startups I did from data science to
data architectures and I do love and my
interests are in data science for sure
time series and generative models
so we are in this era of foundational
models we talk a lot about them and how
they are changing the
Ai and our landscape in terms of data
science but the truth is this type of
models need lots and lots lots of data
so they are very data safety and you
might have not seen that but we all are
aware of chat GPD and we know how much
data it consumes it needs but in one of
the latest articles about it
it was shown that with far less data but
more accurate data we can train a model
as good as the one that we are seeing
being used in cha GPD that's awesome
right so this already tells you a lot
about the importance of data quality
it's not only about how it makes your
model more accurate and better but also
more cost efficient and you can train it
way faster that's that's impressive
so we need to think about data as a
product and it means that we need to
Define really well the business needs at
the heart of our data flows and
preparation for a better design and to
answer better the needs of a business
you might be on wondering how this all
ties up with synthetic data I'll reach
to that part
so what is synthetic data I know you
have the definition here but in case
someone wants to go ahead and tell your
own perception of what is synthetic data
please go ahead
you probably are still a bit shy at the
moment so I'll take that as a not for
now
so synthetic data is artificial
generated data that was not collected
from Real World events it keeps the same
characteristics as the real data and
it's not traceable back to the original
individuals
sounds easy
so
how can we generate synthetic data or
what types of synthetic data can we
consider yes not all synthetic data
records are the same there are different
layers and different aspects to and
different needs for the synthetic data
generation
the one that you probably are aware of
and you might have already used it at
any time of any moment while you are
developing is dummy data you probably
know for example packages like faker
they do deliver you exactly this Demi
data it's useful data for some use cases
for example stress testing systems but
it stated that probably you won't be
using for development of machine
learning
data-driven synthetic data this is the
one I'm going to focus more on this talk
and this is data that we have generated
synthetically based on a Model that was
able to learn
the structure and behavior of the
original data the synthetic data that is
generated is feasible to be used for
machine learning purposes because it
holds the same value and the same
behavior of the original data while
still being synthetic
and last but not the least simulated
data this is probably one that's you
have heard about especially when we have
agent-based simulation but we kind of we
are observing more and more need for
this type of data for example for risk
modeling in financial services this is a
very useful type of synthetic data and
this means that in a simulated scenario
the synthetic data picks up the
characteristics of the real world data
and it enables extrapolation of
scenarios based on past events
another example is when we see an image
from a car
and we want to see that same image of
that car in a snow kind of environment
that simulation and that's still useful
it depends on the business needs
so
okay one of the most common questions
that I get while talking about synthetic
data is why then go synthetic I think
the last slide was already convincing
enough but
if you have real data does not mean your
real data is enough for what you want to
build
and synthetic data can allow you to
become cost in speed or give you less
costs and more speed in terms of their
acquisition can help you to unlock data
sharing and access to data more in a
more timely manner it supports
responsible AI by allowing to the
biasing your data sets it helps in
enhancing the machine learning
performance
and last but not least it can be an
enabler to product testing and
development
now and I promise that I would focus
more on synthetic data driven and that's
exactly what you can see in this diagram
I've shown you in the beginning of the
presentation that one of my passions are
generative models and in this case you
can see three of the different deep
generative models that you can follow
for the generation of synthetic data all
of them will enable you to generate
synthetic data
but all of them have different needs
different requirements and have
different performances in what concerns
the generation of data we have implicit
density explicit density
I know some of you you might have heard
Markov chains yes they are generative
models although they are in the whole
books of Statistics but you also have
models such as generative matching
moment Nets you have generative
adversarial networks you can use as well
variational Auto encoders for the
generation of synthetic data
and in more detail you can use as well
by patient networks for example I'm
going to show you this just to showcase
the difference of the benefits between
different models in different use cases
for example Vision networks are suitable
for smaller and more noisy data sets
they are great to handle the complexity
and dimensionality of data from
verticals such as healthcare for example
and they are able
to the problem is that the order of the
columns of your data do have an impact
on how these models for example behave
which make them hard to have success
with no prior knowledge
they are a hard to scale for larger
volumes of data as well so if you have a
small noisy data set in a vertical where
you have high dimensionality for sure
visual networks are more than enough for
you but if you are in a vertical where
your data sets are very big Vision
networks will be a pain for you
nevertheless they also have one thing
that is very good and
they are very explainable
so when you generate synthetic data
using Bayesian networks you kind of get
an understanding of how your data behave
and how it looks like
Transformers
they are also very good for the
generation of synthetic data and in this
case text NLP image structure data time
series they are pretty flexible in terms
of the data types they can generate
they do not suffer from mood collapse
which is great they easily scale with
the volume of data and can be easily
adapted to different data types
nevertheless they are data saving so
they are not suitable to synthesize
smaller data sets for example Healthcare
probably it's a place where you don't
use Transformers they won't be able to
to generate data unless you have
pre-trained models and you use for
example things like transfer learning
then you might be able to enable a
Transformer architecture for example
they are also hard to explain
and they are very hard to control in
terms of business constraints
and why is this relevant verticals like
Financial Services they require the
explainability of any machine learning
model that you use so if you are using
synthetic data inside of verticals such
as financial care or even a healthcare
you probably don't want to go with this
type of architecture
and last but not least
generative adversary Nets they are super
fun their concept is is really great if
you go and check it's a competition
between two different Networks
and in a min max game so it's an
optimization kind of problem combined
with competition there the the the way
they were created is pretty fantastic
and they are very flexible to different
use cases it's not only synthetic data
they allow they they have different
applications
so this type of architecture does easily
scale with the volume of data and can be
easily adapted as well for different
types of data so NLP structure data time
series images we have seen different
architectures and they are very very
flexible
they do have a huge benefit which is the
introduction of variability to the
generated synthetic data which is great
for privacy compliant use cases
they are hard to optimize and fine-tune
and they can suffer from remote collapse
this is when there are many papers about
the mode collapse in general generative
adversarian Nets and there are just few
about also their optimizations
for example using the traditional
methods for optimization like stochastic
gradients is not great for them it's
almost impossible for you to optimize
this type of network with those you
probably want to go with evolutionary
kind of approaches with genetic
algorithms for example
and
okay this was about
how can I generate it
another question that I commonly get
about synthetic data is how good is my
synthetic data and how can I trust the
synthetic data that was generated
I have to disclose that this is a
tabular data edition if you want to go
for images time series there are nuances
that you should follow when validating
your synthetic data
nevertheless all the data types probably
have these three pillars or Dimensions
where you want to validate your
synthetic data
Fidelity which stands for how similar is
the synthetic data compared to your
original training data so is it
representative of the data that you have
learned from
is it useful
so can it be used for
in replacement of real data for
Downstream applications and downstream
applications can be of course machine
learning models
forecasting systems but it can also be
an analytics system for example just a
dashboard or the construction of a
pipeline or a data engineering pipeline
where you want to do tests
and last but not the least privacy
so do we have in the synthetic data any
leakage from the real data that we have
learned from
and this is probably the the important
part of the definition of privacy here
we are validating if we are leaking from
the data that we have learned from
not validating that the synthetic data
when
released in the real world does not leak
any privacy regarding everything
so this is different because that's the
concept overall of gdpr which is if any
data set is combined with any source of
data internal or external it must not
have any re-identification in this case
the definition of privacy is regarding
re-identification between the original
and the synthetic alone
so this is one of my favorite
sentences of all times this was said by
Manuel of loso from GP Morgan and Chase
the realism of data is overrated and
this is true
um it's true and you have for example
very good use case which I do think it
was Uber who built it out with gtns
where they have shown that they were
able to generate synthetic images that
for a human being they did not make any
sense they we were not able to see cars
people streets nothing it was just
gibberish and
for the models it was one of the best
data that the models could use to
identify the type of patterns they
wanted so that's really a proof that
there are realism of data in real world
data is super overrated
but
and keeping how you can build a system
to validate your synthetic data sets you
should start by ensuring you are not
overfitting let's not forget that
especially for synthetic data driven
you are still using machine learning or
you are still using models for the
generation of that synthetic data so
make sure you do not forget to use the
same principles you you usually do when
you are building your machine learning
model create an old Out Create a set of
data that is unseen by your synthetic
data generator that will allow you and
ensure you that the synthetic data that
is being generated is in reality
generalizing well
you can do different types of holdout
you can do the train test split you can
do cross-validation it depends on your
use case
But be sure to implement this
second you might want to go for a
profiling of your data or exploratory
data analysis or where you just extract
some metrics means maximums
divergency scores
check if the distributions are similar
check if there is missingness and you
are replicating the same missingness as
on your original data this all should be
validated for example are you generating
the same category coverage how are the
outliers behaving on your synthetic data
generation that's what you should
account for in this case I'm just
plotting uh here an image from our open
source the Y data profiling it gives you
the the full profile
of a data set in this case I've used it
also to validate synthetic data
either the so here are the the the the
the some of the metrics that I was
explaining univariate category coverage
numerical range statistical similarity
FID score if you are using images for
example uh divergences like KL
Divergence in a bivariate and
multivariate you might want to go with
pairwise distributions Mutual
information and correlation matrices if
you are using with tabular data don't
forget in your correlations to always
ensure that you are validating
categorical to categorical numerical to
categorical and numerical to numerical
relations don't just use Pearson
straight off okay
utility
Downstream applications it will depend
but these two are probably my preferred
ones
unsupervised if I want to validate
whether my analytic systems or reporting
system will behave as expected
we do prepare a bunch of queries that we
would do to the original data do the
same queries to the synthetic data and
check if the answers match or have a
match within a certain tolerance
you also have the supervised version
which is assuming you know you have a
Target and you want to build a machine
learning model you go and implement the
flow of test synthetic test train sorry
uh yeah I have a typo there so
no trains turn synthetic that's real
sorry for this
where you do train your machine learning
model on the synthetic data and you
validate it on the real one
what does this do you already have your
Baseline right you are able to train
your model on your real data so you know
the performance of your real data if you
train a model on the synthetic data and
you compare the results of the test set
with the of the real data you can get
whether your synthetic data is losing
information and that's how you do it so
you compare the results of your
synthetic data against the the test set
of the real one this is one of the best
ways to ensure that you haven't lost
information of course you had all that
validations around Fidelity but there's
nothing better and more informative than
a tstr
and last but not least about privacy we
have the nearest neighbors or KNN which
validates whether around your synthetic
data how many uh real records do you
have this allows you to go to several
dimensions of comparison and allows you
to understand uh for example whether a
synthetic point was generated out of a
single real record that's a true risk of
leakage for example because you can very
easily re-identify what was the record
that for example was the origin for a
certain synthetic event
the second one
is more complex more interesting and
also more complete in terms of the
validation of privacy
which goes for membership in France
attacks
so what does this mean this means that
in a scenario where we provide synthetic
data to someone
that someone is able to train a model on
top of the synthetic data and afterwards
attack your real data in order to so
attack the synthetic data in order to
re-identify something from your original
data So based on only having access to
your synthetic data can a person by
building a model attack your real data
and know some specifics of the behavior
for example things that are very
dangerous to re-identify or to be able
to reconstruct are what we call
quasi-identifiers like age gender
postal codes all of that even when
redacted can be re-identified and the
access to synthetic data can be a
potential source of more information so
you can reconstruct something on on real
data that's what membership inferences
attack measures in the end there are
more privacy metrics of course but this
are the two more robots that are known
in terms of literature and this again is
only valid for tabular data this is not
valid for example data sets where you
have temporal dependency or you have
relation in between records
for the the membership infrast attack
it's true but not for example k n you
cannot apply k n for time series when
you are validating
um
the privacy of your generated data
so
to wrap it up I have here some examples
of synthetic data in the industry we
have GP Morgan that is using synthetic
data to replace real data for analytics
purposes for example so they have a
problem of access to data there are many
privacy regulations that are blocking
the use of the real data for development
for example so they are using synthetic
data for their purpose
uh Alexa which is in a lot of ways that
trained with synthetic test data
and last but not least on the healthcare
side we have karate lab using synthetic
data for privacy compliance what does
this mean they need to have access to
hospital data and other Healthcare
institutions in order to develop their
Solutions and their research so they are
using synthetic data exactly for their
purpose so they can keep evolving their
investigation in their research in that
sense
so just to wrap it up synthetic data
comes in many forms
it is able to capture the complexity of
many data sets
can be used to address data quality
issues such as missing data biases
augmentation
synthetic data is a cost efficient and
can remove access barriers
and it's an emergent attack that of
course still have some lead mutations
but that has a huge potential
I hope you have enjoyed the talk of
course if you want to geek out we have a
lot of Open Source about it it's MIT
license so you can really explore it you
have to hear the QR codes in case you
want to give it a go afterwards we have
for example I have here that I can show
you a Google collab that you can very
quickly spin in order to use for example
one of the most known gains for tabular
data which is ctgan this is a tensorflow
implementation you can use it right away
just to test out how your synthetic data
will look like
and that's it let me know if you have
questions hope you have enjoyed thank
you
foreign